[Music]
you thought you knew crepes but you were
wrong
click baby opening line and cue title
card
this whole story requires you to know
one basic fact this is not a crepe no
certainly positive
it may look smell and taste like what
you might call a crepe
but soon opposing capsicum add a little
black pepper a Sufi pathology letter a
table Sally
this distinction is a big deal and you
should listen to John Paul because Jean
Paul is the current grand commander of
the Brotherhood of the galette whose
headquarters are here in peep react
France a city in the northern region of
Brittany or Rock tone as they say here
this group comprised of 25 members has
one purpose to keep the tradition of the
Burton galette alive and to protect the
original recipe and its ingredients so
let's start at the beginning what is a
galette una galleta sit in play Donkey
fábrica de la Farina dusassa Yahoo she
knew do cassell de gijón
hey girl model ooh a on pool they wanted
more as a enough pull apart the office
don't bother the severan gelateria catch
super Alethia of cotyledon or the parent
parent castle men
this remote legality SATA port week will
impose a duty a vacay don't work his own
body to elite net for future in the
turkish on developability well so what's
the best way to serve a galette la get
it complete ensemble of hamas
le fameux and Goethe practically
clearly you're wondering about the
costumes don't worry we act like
inferiority creo mino-san que toma de
vita yeah no not customer compare
meadows distingue para por todo confetti
avec
costume katana poor donkey republic new
de fondo not a costume either Kudo
vector sit on a poor Eric don't like it
- you like Philippine well soon emotions
are on in
schon body during the flow of Dublin
where Natasha Pugh a black Queen deletes
a new port on the God kizomba caboose
all of this is to say with tradition
comes a sort of responsibility when a
university like many times we look a
sentencer but he's not on our me away
you noticed we save Exeter and makes
every buku buku akira don't go between a
pop dance video
this seems like a fun group to be a part
of right
[Music]
is this a sandwich how about this or
this the answer is well it depends it's
actually surprisingly complicated
jurisdiction scheme that's Neil Fortin
he's a professor of food law he wrote
the book on it literally just what a
sandwich is is actually defined by the
government
federally it's the USDA and the FDA
defining something matters because it
changes how it's inspected and regulated
the hotdog is regulated by USDA but a
hotdog on a bun is regulated by FDA a
sandwich doesn't have actually a strict
legal definition it's more of the common
term that can lead to some heated
arguments by sandwich purists according
to the USDA the hotdog is not a sandwich
but the dictionary says it is and so
does the state of New York
marek is pretty inclusive on the
sandwich question hi I'm David Greco
this is Mike's deli in the real Little
Italy of the Bronx our list of
sandwiches is at least 50 sandwiches we
have the Bronx Tale the Michelangelo
Sophie Lorraine the Raging Bull the
Yankee big boy come on I'll make you one
special that's a New York sandwich
according to the state's Department of
Taxation and Finance not only is a hot
dog a sandwich but so is a burrito
that's because a burrito counts as a
wrap which in New York is a sandwich
okay so what about this it looks and
acts like a sandwich it's an ice-cream
sandwiches sandwiches I would say that
ice-cream sandwiches is a fanciful name
rather than an actual use of the word
sandwich in the traditional sense
fanciful name delicious sandwich
the USDA disagrees but what do they know
however sandwiches define we know that
there are all kinds of delicious food
wha is it's well simpler and much more
complicated than it looks on the surface
thanks Neil
[Music]
when you think of Sweden what comes to
mind
IKEA ABBA maybe those delicious cinnamon
rolls but what about these Swedish
meatballs right well maybe not
welcome to the meatball mystery let's
cut straight to the chase it's hard to
make the Swedes angry but on one fateful
day something happened that fired up the
whole country this tweet was sent from
the official Sweden Twitter account
Swedish meatballs actually based on a
recipe from King Charles a talk brought
back from Turkey in the early 18th
century let's stick to the facts did you
catch that the tweet said that Swedish
meatballs actually come from Turkey as
you can imagine the tweet went viral
Swedes were up in arms it was picked up
all around the world the Swedish
government has admitted Swedish
meatballs are actually Turkish what what
no that's not affect the facts is really
interesting since we don't have any
effects from that period bye to you my
name is Richard Telstra and I am a food
historian ok here's what we know in the
1700s Swedish King Charles the 12th lost
a battle in the great northern war he
was forced to flee to the Ottoman Empire
where for several years he negotiated
his return the controversy tweet
suggested that he brought back a local
Turkish meat dish called koftas however
there is no documented interest from him
in food no mentioning of the meatballs
though they are not Turkish because we
can't follow the original meatballs in
the world there is no zero meatball
where everything started most likely
origin of the meatball is development in
parallel ways in parallel food cultures
therefore meatballs are very different
all of the world but they exist all over
the world today it's one of Sweden's
most popular dishes traditionally served
with mashed potatoes a brown gravy and a
sweet lingonberry sauce
[Music]
food gives us an example of how we are
connected when it comes to capture food
is a sort of cultural network so take
pride in your meatballs Sweden and so
should Turkey China Italy in every meat
ball rolling country because if there's
one thing the world can agree on is that
meatballs are delicious
when you think of Japanese cuisine a few
foods come to mind sushi did you know
that salmon sushi is actually Norwegian
yeah we did a story on that one maybe
you think of mochi we did that one too
and tempura but guess what tempura is
actually a Portuguese dish oh boy here
we go
the Japanese tempura you know is done
two ways either with seafood or with
vegetables right and the batter is light
made with cold water wheat flour and egg
pretty standard this tempura can be
found dating back to the end of the 16th
century in Japan but as we know Japan is
much older than that so why did it
suddenly show up
the answer is Portugal around 15 43 a
Chinese ship with three Portuguese
sailors got up course and landed in
Japan on Tanegashima Island fast forward
a bit and the Portuguese because of this
happy accident are now trading goods and
arms with the Japanese then in 1639 the
Portuguese were kicked idle country a
few things however remained including a
dish of battered and fried beans called
machines they Orta useful versions
sub-rule cook here pushing your sword
that's Manuela brandão chef I Papa sorta
one of the best spots in Lisbon to get
machines they were thought machine is
the water that was his thing
special very good
Bosley abuse inform the parrot really no
es audible a gradable no second society
who because Racine our OSHA for me is
vision
now of course over the past 400 years
Japan has put its own spin on the dish
but you know it's a fun fact next time
somebody in your group orders tempura
[Music]
[Music]
this is kombucha real kombucha that I
see you buy in those expensive bottles
fermented in Sweden it's good but it's
not kombucha somewhere along the line
the word was lost in translation in
Japanese cha means T and this is kombu
this is the story of the real kombucha
first the konbu konbu is a type of
seaweed and a staple ingredient in
Japanese cuisine and Rishi REE island of
the northernmost tip of Japan has become
known for the kombu that grows here as
any chick Osaka is a third-generation
fisherman tomorrow our condo knock off
okay
you are Bonnie what the day when I was
in America submitted a new show cookie
home not would the Google knocked on her
machine mister do you consume to the
city fishes were on a very rocky mr.
toca how are you going when you discover
kombucha Bertone I like it
[Music]
after kombu is harvested and dried it
can be used to make anything from soup
to salad to garnish but for our purposes
we're gonna make kombucha
Chiharu hirokawa is a shop owner selling
kombucha made from locally harvested
kombu oh that's you oh hello seeing the
morale Kamini oh you did to eat up what
is it come to channel Talk Java let me
know media regard example when you're
hiking must their Caravan II totally
this have to ask do you know about
American kombucha can you guess what
it's like every new home town as a home
you know whom like new or you also saw
the converted a tortoise you are with
the other
sorry nope
but do you have any words for those
seeking real kombucha so des neige
America Jen Okutama Dez Dez de genève oh
no kombucha nandi today their condo
Masada snare yoni honk te hono company -
oh no day today their new Nakata motor
skill not eat a text editor
[Music]